si on fait entrer au Panthéon des femmes
juste parce qu'elles défendent les
femmes alors de la même manière pour les
hommes faudra prévoir une place pour
Bigard et DSK
c'est maintenant j'accueille Gaspard
Proust pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut Gaspard bonjour bonjour C'est
salut salut
je suis vraiment très content de
reprendre je tenais à le dire parce que
ça se voit pas toujours sur mon visage
et c'est un vrai bonheur de donner du
plaisir aux gens
en tout cas public vraiment merci du
fond du cœur pour vos like vos tweets et
enfin tous vos pouces que vous mettez
sous la vidéo sur le site Canal pour
dire que la vidéo est au dessus c'est
c'est vraiment un geste pratique parce
que sinon on la trouverait pas et
alors moi cet été bon je suis assez féru
de culture j'aime pas trop les endroits
chauds donc je suis allé à Dubaï
c'est beau c'est beau Dubaï c'est c'est
comme la défense mais au milieu du Sahel
quoi c'est si tu détestes la nature
c'est vraiment un chouette endroit pour
lâcher prise
[Applaudissements]
alors bon
la main d'oeuvre c'est que des
Pakistanais des Indiens des sri lankaise
ça fait ça fait bizarre au début c'est
parce que de visu physiquement on dirait
un peu des Roms alors
mais en fait il te demande juste alors
est-ce que la viande est bien cuite
encore un mojito et ah on l'a retrouvé
votre portefeuille face ça fait bizarre
au début
et je te parle pas des femmes parce que
là-bas les femmes c'est une pudeur tout
dans les yeux
c'est bon c'est normal tout le reste est
couvert quoi je veux dire tu as
l'impression qu'elle passe leur temps à
chercher un bloc opératoire c'est
vraiment
alors bon au niveau culture je suis pas
rentré bredouille enfin j'ai quand même
visité un musée par là-bas ils appellent
ça un centre commercial c'est alors j'ai
déniché un très très chouette bibelot
que je voulais donc c'est c'est un mug
enfin
osez le féminisme
d'ailleurs j'ai bu une vodka dedans je
me suis trouvé super subversif quoi
bon enfin bref sinon qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé récemment alors le devoir de
vacances des ministres a été de pondre
un rapport sur ce que sera la France en
2025 alors ils sont tous optimiste c'est
le rapport qui aurait pu s'appeler ça
ira mieux quand on sera plus là
c'est genre ces trucs après nous le
paradis quoi
en gros en 2025 tout sera réglé c'est
quand même bizarre quoi des gens de
gauche qui sont convaincus que tout sera
génial quand le FN sera au pouvoir
ça se raconte je veux dire FN en 2025
c'est Philippot ministre de la Justice
Serge Ayoub ministre de la Culture face
à
alors au pif alors dans les prospectives
il y a Montebourg qui prévoit qu'en 2025
il y aura la France qui fera partie du
concert des grandes nations
industrielles il annonce qu'on va
inventer un moyen de transport qui
consomme 2 litres au sang
ça existe déjà ça s'appelle un cheval
[Musique]
puis surtout en 2025 Najat Palau
Belkacem sera majeur
un peu de patience pour les mecs
sinon quoi d'autre alors oui il y a un
mouvement alors j'ai cité oser le
féminisme c'est un peu en vrac qui
milite pour l'entrée des femmes au
Panthéon moi je suis pour après la
question pourquoi seulement des femmes
mortes
alors elles ont toutes en commun un truc
elle défendent la cause des femmes
si on fait entrer au Panthéon des femmes
juste parce qu'elles défendent les
femmes alors de la même manière pour les
hommes faudra prévoir une place pour
Bigard et dska
c'est dans les l'été c'est aussi l'amour
parce que c'est important quoi la love
story de l'été Val stobira et une
révélation la prison crée des
délinquants c'est vrai en général les
mecs qui arrivent en prison c'est parce
qu'ils ont été acquittés
alors on veut réduire la peine de prison
mettre des peines probatoire on a raison
on a raison faut avouer faute à moitié
pardonnée faut des prisons plus
spacieuses et confortables moi je vois
depuis que le Club Med a retapé ses
villages j'ai plus de plaisir à y aller
c'est un truc je sais pas
non faut sortir d'une certaine démagogie
si je peux me permettre
parce que si un mec est en prison c'est
que quelque part il y a une injustice
moi je connais des victimes
qu'est-ce qu'une personne âgée fou avec
100 euros en liquide dans son sac à main
statistiquement 100% des victimes ont
croisé un agresseur
dire la provoque un moment ça suffit
quoi
et on l'oublie mais souvent le
délinquant est plus dans le besoin
financier que la victime
à part ça ouais que j'allais oublier un
truc super important la commémoration
alors il y a une semaine c'était le 50e
anniversaire du discours i had a dream
c'est quand même très émouvant
cet homme qui parce qu'il est noir est
obligé de raconter son rêve en dehors
d'un cabinet de psychiatre
la pauvreté ça pousse toujours à
l'impruder
la Syrie que ça bouge là-bas
c'est les attaques chimiques alors ils
ont envoyé des experts pour vérifier je
sais pas si Christine Boutin était dans
l'équipe parce qu'elle s'est fait gazer
tu vois
[Applaudissements]
et elle connaît bien sûr
pas d'intervention internationale quoi
mais ça c'est notre rapport aux
personnes âgées quand on sera toujours
plus ému par un enfant musulman qui
suffoque une grand-mère catholique qui
tousse
et le problème c'est c'est le côté c'est
le mot chimique c'est le côté gazage ça
rappelle les heures sombres quoi c'est
les gens ils supportent pas quoi ça leur
rappelle trop quand il se trouve coincé
aux heures de pointe sur le péril dans
un tunnel Bagnolet
en fait les armes chimiques c'est un peu
comme la fellation quoi comme sucer
n'est pas trompé flinguer n'est pas
exterminé
c'est un peu ça c'est pas
en tout cas là maréchal des logis chefs
Hollande il va y aller
c'est à côté d'Obama c'est le jardin de
Saint-Tropez qui tire la bourre avec
Rambo
ça c'est
[Applaudissements]
ça s'explique c'est l'effet Mali quoi
depuis qu'il a cartonné là-bas
du mec qui vient tout juste de perdre
son pucelage quoi c'est le type il vient
de se taper la fille facile du village
et qui va raconter à tous ses potes
c'est le loup blanc dans tous les bars à
[ __ ] de Saigon
il faut expliquer un peu la Syrie c'est
c'est un pays c'est pas un paysage quoi
c'est
chef du village c'est pas un chaman qui
lit dans les entrailles de patates
douces
parce que Bachar il a une certaine
classe
tu lui mets à haute forme un parapluie
c'est Englishman à Damas
après faut être juste
est-ce que la France peut intervenir
toute seule oui
on a envoyé une frégate deux audiaces
enfin c'est bon on parle aussi de deux
ULM peut-être 3 si un Artus Bertrand
répond oui tu vois
[Applaudissements]
on va finir par une bonne nouvelle pas
plomber sur la guerre alors la location
adulte handicapé va aussi augmenter de
1,75% cette année joli coup de pouce
pour pouvoir d'achat des fonctionnaires
alors
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu